et on va plus loin avec comme chaque
lundi Annie va reporter de guerres
indépendantes bonjour Anne oui bonjour
face à vous Bruno Darroux chroniqueur
internationale sur France 24 bonjour
Bruno bonjour Raphaël des retraités des
invalides ou tout simplement des malades
ou des personnes sans aucune expérience
militaire la mobilisation sonnait la
semaine dernière par Vladimir Poutine
n'a pas donné pour l'heure les résultats
escomptés c'est le Kremlin même qu'il
admet dans un rare mea culpa le pouvoir
russe qu'on fait une erreur voilà ce que
dit le porte-parole Mitry PS4 en effet
ce sont ces mots il y a des cas où le
décret de mobilisation a été violée dans
certaines régions les gouverneurs
travaillent activement pour rectifier
les choses nous espérons que toutes les
erreurs seront corrigées une bévue qui
fait tâche en tout cas à l'heure où de
nombreux Russes manifestent ou bien fui
le pays pour ne pas avoir à combattre en
Ukraine ainsi la présidente de la
Chambre du Parlement la pourtant très
proboutine Valentina un advienne Cohn ne
m'en manque pas d'émettre une mise en
garde des cas injustifiés immobilisation
entraîne de vivre et actions dans la
société et à juste titre dit-elle c'est
inacceptable assurez-vous que la
mobilisation partielle est effectuée
dans le respect total et entier des
critères et sans une seule erreur voilà
la manière dont elle-même se permet
d'admmonester aujourd'hui les autorités
la Russie accumule les erreurs anniva
vous êtes vous-même surprises de voir
cette approximation finalement y compris
dans la mobilisation bien figurez-vous
rafale que je ne suis pas tellement
surprise je ne suis pas tellement
surprise parce que je connais pas mal la
Russie et qu'une mobilisation d'une
telle ampleur Vladimir Poutine a dit
qu'elle n'était que partielle mais le
fait est que elle secoue tout le monde
dans un si grand pays avec tous ces
fuseaux horaires et qui n'est que la
troisième depuis enfin dans le troisième
après l'avant-dernière qui était celle
de la grande guerre patriotique
c'est-à-dire la Seconde Guerre mondiale
effectivement on sent un manque
d'organisation c'est très clair et ça a
été c'est reconnu au moins c'est reconnu
mais tout ça ne va pas faire avancer les
choses en fait ce qui est important
c'est de ce que l'on voit c'est que
alors il n'y a pas le mot d'exode est
trop fort il n'y a pas une majorité de
Russes qui quitte la Russie mais on ne
peut pas dire que les Russes acceptent
tous cette mobilisation ça veut donc
dire que le fait que cette guerre fasse
irruption dans leur vie privée alors que
jusqu'à présent elle était lointaine et
bien aujourd'hui ça change la donne et
c'est les conséquences que Vladimir
Poutine va devoir affronter aujourd'hui
c'est à dire le fait que son peuple ne
le voit plus tout à fait de la même
façon au-delà des erreurs que confesse
le pouvoir russe Bruno à la mobilisation
ne fait pas recette c'est ce qu'on
observe depuis la semaine dernière bah
en tout cas effectivement c'est
difficile à dire dans le cas de la
Russie parce que effectivement c'est en
tout cas c'est une minorité et puis on
n'a pas suffisamment d'image c'est pas
suffisamment documenté mais déjà ce
qu'on voit alors on a un coup de feu
aujourd'hui dans un centre oui il y a eu
aussi une immolation par le feu qui a
été documenté et sans doute plus
d'après d'après certaines observateurs
indépendants donc voilà c'est difficile
de mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène mais
il y a un phénomène il y a à peu près
pas loin de 300000 personnes on sait qui
ont qui sont déjà
sont rendus aux différentes frontières
de la Russie pour quitter le pays donc
c'est le nombre de personnes quand on
est mobiliser
sauf que en plus on a on a maintenant de
découvert que dans le décret
présidentiel il y avait le fameux
article 7 qui est qui où il y avait
marqué en quelque chose du genre
confidentiel mais finalement ça a fuité
et qui indiquait qu'en fait et prévoyait
de mobiliser un million de cent mille
personnes et donc aujourd'hui à l'heure
des réseaux sociaux même dans des états
hyper verrouillés comme la Russie et
bien effectivement ça atteint les gens
et ils se disent bah finalement demain
ce sera moi ce sera moi plus
effectivement le phénomène un peu
nouveau je sais pas si c'est nouveau
mais en tout cas là ça touche pas
simplement les grands centres urbains
mais ça touche des effectivement des
provinces très reculées comme là yakouti
parce que c'est là aussi que dans un
premier temps euh le Kremlin avait
recruté voilà avait recruté voilà des un
peu des des paysans pour caricaturer un
peu et là ça passe plus parce que ce
sont des familles qui ont déjà été
marqués par la guerre qui ont eu des
morts etc et là visiblement il y a quand
même un problème plus visiblement une
très mauvaise organisation de l'appareil
d'État comme de l'appareil militaire
russe d'ailleurs qu'on a constaté sur le
terrain bon là c'est à certains proches
de Poutine disent que évidemment ce sont
les cadres locaux chargés du recrutement
qu'il ne faut pas bien leur travail donc
ça rappelle un peu le vieux système
soviétique qui fait que quand quelque
chose ne marche pas on prépare les on
prépare les responsabilités pour les
échelons inférieurs il y a un sentiment
d'injustice à la population n'aurait
cherché à recruter en priorité dans des
zones pauvres et isolées
non alors formellement évidemment non
officiellement ce recrutement cette
mobilisation partielle elle touche tous
les sujets de la Fédération de Russie
mais en Russie il y a pas forcément une
égalité tout le monde se débrouille et
là effectivement le Kremlin
renvoie la balle si je puis dire au
gouverneur les gouverneurs qui sont élus
et pardon je fais un lapsus ils ont été
élus dans les années 90 ils sont
maintenant nommés les gouverneurs sont
nommés justement par Vladimir Poutine et
donc ils obéissent à venir Poutine mais
c'est à eux aujourd'hui que revient
cette lourde responsabilité je voudrais
juste dire un mot sur le fait qui est
assez étonnant ce que je constate depuis
plusieurs jours et beaucoup
d'observateurs russes le disent là où il
y a le plus de contestations c'est au
d'aggestant le Dagestan c'est une
république du Nord Caucase qui voisine
la Tchétchénie alors et ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand Tchétchénie on a
justement aucune contestation puisqu'on
a Ramzan Kadirov qui lui dit ah mais moi
j'en ai déjà tellement envoyé que j'ai
pas besoin de mobiliser donc
face aux fuites de ressortissants parce
qu'il y a aussi des départs vous l'avez
dit Bruno vous parlez de 270 000
personnes à aux frontières l'Europe elle
se divise faut-il ou non les accueillir
bah alors clairement évidemment les pays
voisins de la Russie qui ont gardé un
mauvais souvenirs évidemment de
l'expérience soviétique n'en veulent pas
à la différence de ce qu'ils ont fait de
l'effort qu'ils ont fait pour les
ressortissants Ukrainiens ils ne voient
pas des dissidents qu'il faudrait
peut-être aider justement pour l'exemple
apparemment ce sont les pays baltes
sur les pays balles tout la Pologne ils
ont pas vraiment envie de les voir
arriver chez eux ça c'est clair alors il
y a l'Allemagne qui se dit prête en
accueillir et puis après les autres qui
pour le moment reste la France y compris
d'ailleurs dans un silence très très
prudent quand même j'ai pas entendu de
déclaration des autorités françaises
disant comme ça a été mis en place pour
les Ukrainiens des procédures par
exemple le droit d'asile accéléré etc
j'ai absolument pas entendu ça pour
l'instant on craint quoi au passage des
infiltrations des bah c'est ça qui est
très étonnant c'est moi personnellement
je suis quand même très gênée par ce par
ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui montre
c'est juste il y a lu qui par contre si
vous voulez venir chez nous oui ou alors
oui rendez-vous
ce qui ce qui est évidemment va dans son
intérêt c'est normal mais nous en Europe
je pense que il est il serait quand même
important qui est un véritable débattu
or vous vous souvenez Raphaël qu'il y a
pas si longtemps on a déjà eu du mal à
trouver une opinion commune un avis
commun justement pour modifier la façon
dont on recevrait ou pas les Russes
cette question du visa cette question du
visa des citoyens russes dans les pays
de l'Union européenne elle est encore
intrinsèquement solidaire du régime là
on a affaire à des gens qui fuient de
leur propre chef alors il y a des ce
sont des gens qui fouillent mais d'aucun
disent que ils n'ont pas fuit tout de
suite c'est-à-dire qu'il y aurait une
différence entre ceux qui auraient fui
tout de suite et ceux qui fuient
maintenant et qui ne fuiraient que parce
ils n'ont pas envie d'aller sur le front
de se mettre en danger alors
je pense que tout ça est compliqué à
juger et puis qui sommes-nous pour juger
mais en tout cas ce qu'il faudrait de
toute façon c'est une position commune
des 27 que nous n'avons pas pour le
moment de la morale juste en plus il y a
quand même une difficulté peut-être le
juridique entre les vrais déserteurs
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont reçu leur hors
de mobilisation puis et puis les autres
qui pour le moment n'ont rien reçu et
qui se disent bon avant que je reçoive
quelque chose je m'en vais donc après
quel statut on donne à cela comment on
fait la différence entre les déserteurs
et les noms des acteurs enfin voilà
c'est c'est je pense que c'est compliqué
d'un point de vue juridique et dans ce
contexte mitripeeskov a laissé entendre
avec une fermeture des frontières n'est
pas exclue pour empêcher justement ces
départs en âge de combat ça vous semble
possible oui c'est tout à fait possible
et je vous rappelle que c'est le cas en
Ukraine dans un dans un pays en guerre
en Ukraine enfin moi j'ai j'ai été sur
le terrain en Ukraine tout le monde le
sait les hommes en âge de combattre
n'ont absolument pas le droit de quitter
le pays n'ont pas le droit de passer la
frontière et je je vous rappelle que je
voulais un chauffeur pour passer de la
de l'Ukraine à la Moldavie on m'a dit il
va falloir que ça soit une femme ça peut
pas être un homme puisque les hommes ne
doivent pas sortir donc c'est ce qui se
passe en temps de guerre donc ça serait
pas anormal que ça se passe en Russie et
d'ailleurs il me j'ai l'impression que
sinon pas fait tout de suite c'est pour
se réserver le droit de le faire dans
quelques temps mais justement aussi
parce que le narratif rappelez-vous
quand même le narratif des autorités
russes c'est que ce n'était pas une
guerre
maintenant non mais même il continue à
parler d'opération spéciale maintenant
mais ça a été utilisé dans les médias
russes donc aujourd'hui toutes les
changer ce n'est plus une opération je
pense que dans la dans la dans la
réticence la résistance actuelle aussi
de pas mal de la conscription il y a
effectivement l'idée que ce n'est pas
finalement pendant des mois on a dit que
c'était simplement une opération
militaire en Ukraine et maintenant c'est
une guerre et on nous demande d'y aller
et c'est ça qui pose problème bien sûr
nommer les choses souvent on dit c'est
effectivement le premier pas on en est
pas pour la visiblement au niveau du
Kremlin c'est peut-être en tout cas le
maillon faible dans le cordon sanitaire
que l'Europe reste depuis 7 mois
maintenant avec la Russie l'Italie
change de pouvoir et peut-être même de
régime avec l'avènement de l'extrême
droite au sein d'une coalition
conservatrice c'est elle Georges
jameloni que les Italiens ont porté en
tête de leur suffrage et elle promet
déjà la fin de la fête européenne
écoutez là
il se dit qu'en Europe ils sont un peu
inquiets au sujet de mélodie
et de ce qui va se passer la fête va se
terminer l'Italie va être capable de
défendre ses intérêts
il faut le dire sur la guerre elle est
plutôt pro-ukrainienne Bruno mais ce
n'est pas le cas de son allié Matéo
Salvini de la Ligue oui alors
franchement je sais pas si ça va être le
problème essentiel de Madame mélony son
premier problème c'est de composer son
gouvernement parce qu'elle est comme
d'autres dirigeants dirigeantes un peu
d'extrême droite c'est-à-dire que là
derrière elle pas grand monde à la 2 ou
3 personnalités de qualité en termes de
personnel
compétences à la fois politique et
professionnelle et technique elle a pas
grand monde derrière elle au sein de son
parti donc elle est en train là de
négocier avec les deux autres parties
mais sur cette question précisément de
l'Ukraine et de la Russie certes la
Ligue et Forza Italia sont pas sur la
même ligne mais quand même ils compris
parce que mon expression une claque aux
élections donc ils sont pas en position
de force et pour le moment c'est quand
même elle qui est en position de force
et à la déclaré que elle restait quand
même atlantiste en fait de ce point de
vue elle est plutôt proche non pas du
Victor hormone mais du pis polonais
salut sa victoire c'est très à la droite
de l'échiquier mais qui est très très
pro américain donc de ce point de vue là
je sais pas si ça va faire beaucoup de
de remous au sein au sein de de la
coalition encore faut-il encore une fois
qu'ils arrivent à composer cette
coalition il se dit qu'elle est même
prête à aller chercher un à représentant
de la Banque centrale européenne un ex
pas Mario Draghi un autre parce pour
être ministre de l'Économie parce que
franchement il faut quelqu'un qui tienne
un peu la route alors qu'elle a dénigré
absolument ces technocrate vendue à
Bruxelles etc ça vous inquiète one se
tournant de Little au moment où l'Europe
a besoin plus que jamais d'afficher son
unité face à la Russie face à la crise
énergétique
mais je crois que il faut il faut
oser regarder les choses en face nous
avons en Europe plusieurs pays dont la
France
qui dans lesquelles beaucoup de citoyens
votent pour ce genre de partie puisque
nous avons eu le cas avec Marine Le Pen
lors des élections législatives où je
vous rappelle que son nom de députés a
été multiplié grandement et nous avons
récemment la Suède
sans doute il y a aussi en Espagne ce
parti qui est très important donc c'est
une nouvelle Europe c'est une Europe
avec laquelle il faut
discuter il faut le principe même d'être
ensemble 27 pays en Europe
oblige maintenant à maintenant que nous
reconnaissons que nous avons tous des
histoires contemporaines extrêmement
différentes à tenir compte les uns des
autres à nous respecter les uns les
autres et ça n'est pas facile nous avons
une guerre en Europe et nous avons des
parties d'extrême droite qui sont en
train de prendre le pouvoir donc ça fait
deux sujets
peut-être inquiétant le mot est
peut-être un peu trop fort mais en tout
cas il faut être face à cela il y a un
risque de bascule en Europe Bruno avec
cet axe qu'on voyait des pays de
vice-grade c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle d'Europe de l'Est qui pourrait
voir arriver peut-être un allié sur les
rives de la Méditerranée ah bah ils vont
voir arriver à un allié ça va renforcer
ce courant là clairement notamment au
sein des institutions européennes bon
après il y a quand même 27 pays c'est
pas un courant encore majoritaire mais
ça doit quand même servir peut-être un
peu d'alerte effectivement
à certains partis sans trop droit centre
gauche et Parti de Gauche aussi quand
même qui veulent pas trop voir la
réalité en face et notamment le problème
parce que si vous regardez que ce soit
la Suède ou l'Italie c'est un peu le
même problème c'est à dire c'est des
flux migratoires pas très bien contrôlés
qui sont qui sont arrivés très récemment
en quelques années et qui et les gens
les le peuple a estimé que la question
[Musique]
oui enfin un allié ça reste à voir c'est
c'est c'est pas simple
personnellement et le pis ça salut
sélector et c'est vrai que ce cocktail
pro-ukraine anti-avortement correspond
exactement la loi de polonaise mais la
Pologne je ne crois pas que le que ce
que cette jeune femme la politique elle
va mener en Italie sera la même que
celle qui est menée en Pologne
franchement je ne crois pas et je crois
que le vote italien correspond aussi
quand même à une espèce de dégagisme si
je puis dire qui était une conception
plutôt française de d'essayer encore
ceux qui n'avaient pas été au pouvoir
ceux qui en dernier recours finalement
donc j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt
ça auquel on assiste en Italie
aujourd'hui et non pas véritablement une
envie un besoin la fin du plafond de
verre finalement qui pourrait être
prémonitoire pour ce qui se passerait
demain en France du plafond de l'air pas
le Platon de verre à la fin du plafond
de verre ouais effectivement alors en
[Musique]
il faut quand même écouter ce que disent
il faut que les votants les électeurs il
faut que les parties de gauche
trouvent une autre manière de traiter
les problèmes diabolisation et
d'insécurité plutôt que de faire
simplement de la diabolisation merci
Bruno merci Anne c'était ton va plus
loin restez avec nous on se retrouve
dans 3 minutes pour un nouveau journal